สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
3 เดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 2
566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  2  3 ค่ะค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 7:00 นโห 7 นกี่นาที 3
นาทีค่ะค่ะ 73 นทีก็เป็นตอนเช้านะคะเช้า
มากๆอใช่ค่ะครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงยังไม่ตื่นนะ
คะตื่นแล้วสิคะครูฟ้าตื่นแล้วใช่มยตื่น
แล้วนะคะใช่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
เช้าทุกวันนะตื่น 6 นแล้วก็ 700 นเนี่ย
ทุกวันใช่มั้ยคะวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธ
วันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
ทุกวันเนี่ยเรา 2 คนเนี่ยตื่นเช้าใช่มั้ย
คะใช่
ค่ะจริงเหรอคะครูฟ้า
จริงใช่มั้ยคะ
จริงครูฟ้าอ้าไม่รู้สิก็ครูวันนี้ 7:00 น
อ่ะเราก็ตื่นแล้วไงเราตื่นเช้าทุกวันอื
ถูกต้องค่ะตื่นเช้าทุกวันอืครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เคยตื่น 5:00 น
มยเคยตื่น 5:00 นมั้ยคะหรือว่าไม่เคยตื่น
ต 5:00 นเลยลูกฟ้าเคยตื่น 5:00 นค่ะ
หืตื่นเสร็จแล้วก็อาบน้ำแล้วก็ไปโรงเรียน
เหรอคะใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยตอนไปโรงเรียนครู
ฟ้าตื่น 5:00 นทุกวันอ๋ออืแล้วก็อาบน้ำ
แล้วก็ไปโรงเรียนนะคะ
อื 5:00 นตอนุครูหญิงไม่เคยตื่น 5:00 น
แล้วก็อาบน้ำใช่ไหมมเ้าอาบน้ำทั้งนี้ก็
ได้นะคะครูหญิงอาบน้ำแล้วก็ไปโรงเรียน
เนี่ยไม่
เคยไม่เคยเลยตั้งแต่ครูหญิงเครูหญิงไปโรง
เรียนตั้งแต่อายุ 6 ขวบใช่มั้ยคะจนถึง
มหาลัยเลยแล้วกันเนาะอายุ 22 เนี่ยอันนี้
เราเรียนหนังสือใช่มยเรายังเรียนหนังสือ
อยู่ไม่เคยตื่นตีหนแล้วก็ไปโรงเรียนโหครู
หญิงแล้วครูหญิงตื่นกี่โมงอ่ะูหญิงไม่เคย
ตื่นหิงใช่ครุหญิงตื่นประมาณ 6:00 น
มั้ง 6:00 นหรือว่า 7 นอ 18:00 น 700 น
เนี่ยตื่นแล้วก็อาบน้ำใช่มยอาบ
น้ำแปรงฟันใส่เสื้อใส่กระโปรงอืออืแล้วก็
ไปโรงเรียนเนี่ยไม่เคยตื่น 5:00 นไปโรง
เรียนพอเรียนหนังสือจบใช่มั้ยอายุ 23 ปี
จนถึงตอนนี้
2023 เนี่ยอือก็ทำงานก็ไม่เคยตื่น 5:00
นแล้วก็ไปออฟฟิศก็ไม่เคยโอโหผู้
หญิงตื่น 18 น 7 นทุกครั้งนะคะอืมครูฟ้า
เนี่ยตื่น 5:00 น
ค่ะ 5:00 น 5 น 5 นนะคะอืแต่ครูวก็เคยถทำ
งาน่ะไปทำงานครูฟ้าตื่นครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอายุ
23 ใช่มั้ยจนถึงตอนเนี้ยครูฟ้าไปทำงาน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเคยตื่น 5:00 นแล้วก็ไปทำงานม
อันนี้ไม่ได้ไปโรงเรียนแล้วเนาะเราเรียน
จบแล้วนะคะค่ะก็ไปทำงานที่
ออฟฟิศตอนไปทำงานเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าไม่เคย
ตื่น 5:00 นค่ะอืตอนไปออฟฟิศอ่ะนะไปทำงาน
ครูฟ้าไม่ตื่น 5:00 นไปทำงานค่ะครูฟ้า
ตื่น 18:00 น
อ่าครูฟ้าเคยตื่น 5:00 นตอนไปโรงเรียนเฉย
ๆใช่มั้ยคะใช่ตื่น 5:00 นตอนไปโรงเรียน
แต่ว่าไปทำงานไม่ตื่น 5:00 นอือืใช่ค่ะ
นั่นแหละคุหญิงก็เลยเลยคิดว่าเออวดีโอนี้
นะคะเราก็เลยจะมาคุยกันว่าเราเนี่ยไม่เคย
ทำอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยใช่มั้ยเคยตื่น
5:00 นแล้วก็ไปไปโรงเรียนใช่มั้ยไปโรง
เรียนครูฟ้าเคยแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่เคยไม่
เคยตื่น 5:00 นไปโรงเรียนเลยเราก็เลยจะมา
คุยกันว่าเอ๊ะอะไรที่เรา 2 คนเนี่ยไม่เคย
ทำเลย
ตั้งแต่ครูหญิงเกิดมาใช่มยอายุ 0 ขวบอ้า 0
มี S ได้ยไงคะจนถึงตอน
นี้อายุ 37 เนี่ยนะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่เคย
ทำอะไรเลยแล้วก็ครูฟ้าครูฟ้านี่ 27 เนาะ
ใช่ตั้งแต่ครูฟ้าเกิดจนครูฟ้าอายุ 27 ปี
ครูฟ้าไม่เคยทำอะไรเลยอือืได้ค่ะครูหญิง
เคยทำอะไรไม่เคยทำอะไรใช่เคยทำอะไรไม่เอา
นะคะเราเอาไม่เคยทำอะไรที่แบบจริงๆคน
ธรรมดาใช่มั้ยผู้ชายผู้หญิงทั่วๆไปเนี่ย
อาจจะเคยทำแต่ครูหญิงครูฟ้าไม่เคยทำอื
เหมือนครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดออกอย่างนึงค่ะครู
ฟ้าของครูหญิงคืออะไรอ่าครูหญิงใช่มั้ย
อันนี้คือครูหญิงนะคะคะอันนี้มีผมอยู่ที่
นี่แล้วก็ปล่อยผมอย่างงี้ใช่มยอุ๊ยผมน้อย
นะคะตอน
เนี้ยอ่านี้ใช่มั้ยผมเนี่ยครูหญิงเนี่ย
เป็นคน
ไทยผมเนี่ยสีดำใช่มั้ยคะผมสีดำอืซึ่งผู้
หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงส่วนใหญ่นะน่าจะซัก 60
ถึง 70% เนี่ยเคยเปลี่ยนสีผม
โอเปลี่ยนสีผมส่วนเป็นสีน้ำตาลมยครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะสีน้ำตาลใช่มเปลี่ยนสีผมเนี่ยอื
อ่าจากผมสีดำแล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นผมสีน้ำตาล
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยเปลี่ยนสีผมหรือเปล่า
ไฮไลท์ได้นะคะสีเขียวด้วยใช่ใช่ไฮไลท์ก็
ได้เออแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยตั้งแต่ครูหญิงเกิด
มาเกิดมาจากท้องคุณแม่เนี่ยนะคะนี่ครู
หญิงอยู่ที่นี่ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ปุ้งออกมา
เนี่ยจนถึงตอนเนี้ยปี
2023 ครูหญิงไม่เคยเปลี่ยนสีผมเลยจริง
หรอจริงครูฟ้าคุหญิงเนี่ยผมสีดำแบบนี้
ตั้งแต่เกิดจนถึงตอนเนี้ยอายุ 37 แล้ว
แล้วเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนไม่เคยเปลี่ยนสีผม
เลยหููหญิงทำไมอ่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยเคยคิดนะ
เคยบอกครูฟ้าด้วยครูหญิงเคยคิดคิดอยาก
เปลี่ยนสีผมแต่ไม่อยากเปลี่ยน 100% ทั้ง
ผมนะคะเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเคยคิดว่าอ่ะผมเราสี
นี้ใช่มยแล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยอยากได้สีม่วงสี
ม่วงตรง
นี้อืลายผมปลายผมใช่มั้ยคะแต่ก็ไม่ได้ทำ
คิดเฉยๆเ่าคุณหญิงก็เลยไม่เคยเปลี่ยนสีผม
เลยค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าไม่เคยทำอะไร
บ้างครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะจริงๆเมื่อกี้คิดออก
อย่างนึงแต่ลืมไปะอ้าวเอา
กันเมื่อกี้คิดอะไรครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะอันนี้ครูฟ้าเหรออันนี้ครูฟ้าอันนี้คือ
หน้าของครูฟ้านะคะนัก
เรียนครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนไม่เคยอะไ
อะไไม่เคย
ยิ้มใช่ค่ะไม่
ใช่ไม่เคยดัดฟัน
อ่าอันนี้ที่ฟันใช่มั้ยอืออืเพราะว่าบาง
คนเนี่ยอาจจะเคยดัดฟันใช่มั้ยคะฟันเนี่ย
พวกครูฟ้าเนี่ยฟันสวยหน้าเนี่ยธรรมดานะคะ
แต่ฟันเนี่ยสวยุหญิงคิดว่าต้องมีคนเนี่ย
ถามครูฟ้าว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าฟันสวยครูฟ้า
เนี่ยดัดฟันกี่ปีอไม่มีมีอะไรอย่างงี้ใช่
มั้ยอย่างเงี้ยใช่
อ่าแล้วก็ใส่ที่ฟันใช่มยครูฟ้าเนี่ยดัด
ฟันกี่
ปีครูฟ้าไม่เคยดัดฟันโองั้นฟันที่เราเห็น
ก็คือเป็นฟันครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเกิดมาแล้วก็โต
ใช่มอายุ 1 ขวบ 2 ขวบจนถึงอายุเท่าไหร่
เราจะมีฟันอันนี้ประมาณ 10 ขวบมั้ยใช่ค่ะ
ค่ะ 10 ขวบก็ฟันเป็นแบบนี้จนถึงตอนนี้ครู
ฟ้าอายุ
27 ก็ฟันแบบนี้ไม่เคยดัดฟันใช่ค่ะขนาด
คุณหมอใช่
มยคุณหมอหน้าเบี้ยว
ังตัวเองสวยนะคะครูฟ้าอ้าแล้วทำไมลบไม่
หมดคุณหมอหมอฟันน่ะเหรอคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะหมอ
ฟันทำไมหมอฟันมีอะไรที่หัวด้วย
อืเวลาที่เราจะไปดูแลถ้านักเรียนคิดจะดัด
ฟันใช่มั้ยมีเหล็กที่ฟันเนี่ยใส่อันเนี้ย
นะใส่เหล็กอือแล้วก็อันนี้ฟันของเราใช่
มั้ยอื
อืเฟันนะอ้าทำไมฟันเรามันเท่ากันจังเลยนะ
คะใส่เหล็กดัดฟันเนี่ยนักเรียนก็ต้องไปหา
หมอฟัน
อืหมอฟันว่ายังไงคะครูฟ้าหมอฟันก็บอกครู
ฟ้าว่าครูฟ้าเคยดัดฟันใช่มั้ยอือืแปลว่า
ฟันครูฟ้าเหมือนฟันคนที่ดัดฟันใช่ค่ะครู
ฟ้าไปหาหมอฟัน 2 คนนะคะหมอฟันพูดว่าครู
ฟ้าเคยดัดฟันใช่มั้ยอือเลยบอกแล้วครูฟ้า
เครูฟ้าไม่ค่ะครูฟ้าไม่ไม่เคยดัดฟันนะนัก
เรียนอาจจะดูวีีดีโอแล้วก็เห็นครูฟ้ายิ้ม
แล้วก็อุ๊ยฟันครูฟ้าสวยใช่มมันเท่ากันน่ะ
ฟันบนฟันล่างใช่มยอ่านักเรียนอาจจะคิด
เอ๊ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยดัดฟันหรือเปล่าแต่ครู
ฟ้าไม่เคยดัดฟันไม่เคยค่ะครูเออใช่ครูฟ้า
ก็ไม่เคยครูหญิงก็ไม่เคยดัดฟันใช่มั้ยครู
หญิงก็ไม่เคยดัดฟันค่ะใช่เมื่อก่อนก็มีคน
ถามครูหญิงเหมือนกันนะแต่หมอฟันเนี่ยไม่
เคยนะคะก็มีคนคิดว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยเคยดัด
ฟันดัดฟันอ่าแต่คุณหญิงก็ไม่เคยนะคะไม่
เคยดัดฟันเหมือนกันอันนี้เรา 2 คนเนี่ย
ไม่เคยทำแล้วก็มีอีกอย่าง
นึง
กินเอาเรื่องกิน
บ้างอะไรซึ่งอ้าปกติอ่ะทุกคนเนี่ยกินหมู
ใช่มคะอ่ะคนเนี่ยกินหมูกิน
ไก่ค่ะอืกินปลาไกหายหายไปเหขากินกุ้งมีขา
เดียวนะขี้เกียจวาดต่อใช่มกินกุ้งแล้วก็
นักเรียนก็จะ
กินเนื้อวัววะมันเป็นอย่างงี้มยครู
ฟ้า
หิงอะไรออวัวค่ะครูฟ้าทำไมอ่ะไม่เหมือน
เหรอนักเรียนคะครูฟ้าบูลี่วัวครูหญิง
ออืเหมือนวัวขึ้นมั้ยจะเหมือนอ่าเนื้อวัว
นะคะครูหญิงคิดว่าอันนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
อาจจะเหมือนกันไหครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยกินเนื้อ
หมูเคยกินเนื้อไก่เคยกินกุ้งเคยกินปลาครู
ฟ้าเคยกินเนื้อวัวมั้ยไม่เคยค่ะ
เอ้ยเคยเคยมั้ยอ้าวเหรออืตอนเด็กๆนะษาคิด
ว่าไม่เคยูฟ้าไม่รู้ว่าคืออะไรก็เลยกินออ
อออก็เลยงั้นนักเรียนครูหญิงขอโทษคนที่
รักหมาด้วยนะ
คะคือต้องขอโทษนะเพราะนักเรียนอาจจะรู้
สึกว่าแบบอะไรเนี่ยผู้หญิง
อืเ้าก็คนไทยเนี่ยกินหมา
ไงฟ้าบอกว่ามันไม่ใช่อาหารปกติ
มยครูฟ้าเคยกินมยครูฟ้าไม่กินค่ะู
หญิงโอเคค่ะขอโทษค่ะแล้วครูฟ้ามีอะไรที่
ไม่เคยกิน
ไหนี่ไง
พัทยาพัทยาซิตี้อ่ะกินกันเยอะนะอะไร
อ่ะออครูหญิงครูหญิงเคยไอครูหญิงคิดด่า
อีกอย่างนึงพอครูฟ้าบอกว่าพัทยาซิตี้อะไร
อ่ะ
คะะแมวมีตัวอะไรนี่แมวเหรอไม่รู้ตัวอะไร
ไงคือคิดว่าไม่ใช่หมาแน่นอนไง
จระเข้ใช่มยใช่จระเข้มยคะ
ใช่จระเข้มั้ยครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะอ๋อพัทยาเค้า
กินจระเข้กันด้วยเหรอคะครูฟ้ากินค่ะเนี่ย
นักเรียน
จระเข้เสร็จแล้วว่าอะไรเยอะครูฟ้านจระเข้
นะครูฟ้าไม่เคยกินเนื้อ
จระเข้ไม่เคยเพว่าไม่เคยกินเนื้อจระเข้
เลยนะคะอืออืนั่นแหละแต่พัทยาเนี่ยกินนะ
แล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ไปเดินครูฟ้าก็เห็นคน
ขายเนื้อจระเข้เยอะๆนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้า
ไม่อยากลองกินหรอแบบเอ๊มันจะอร่อยมน
อื 20 บาทใช่มันจะเป็นไม้อย่างเงี้ยยมัน
มีอุยจระเข้จริงๆใช่มั้ย 20 บาทเนี่ยใช่
แต่มันน้อยนะคผู้หญิงไม่ได้เยอะหรอกนิด
หน่อยเป็น้บารบีคิว
อือไม้ละ 1  1 ไม้ 20 บาทค่ะอือือนี่แหละ
ครูฟ้าก็ไม่เคยกินจระเข้ค่ะอือืครูหญิง
ครูหญิงคิดออกอย่างนึงครูฟ้าอะไรู้หญิง
เนี่ยเป็นคนชอบกินซาชิมินะคะอาจจะเป็น
ซาชิมิปลาใช่มยปลาแซลมอนเนี่ยซาชิมิอาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นเนาะอืปลาแซลมอนมันสีส้มๆสมใช่มสี
ส้มๆอย่าเงี้ยอ่าเนี่ยปลาแซลมอนซาชิมิใช่
มั้ยคะแต่ว่ามันจะมีคนไทยเนี่ยเขาจะนิยม
มีอีกช่วงนึงประมาณปี
2022  2021 เนี่ยเขาจะฮิตกินซาชิมิปลลา
หมึกอืใช่มมันจะเราจะออกไปที่ทะเลแล้วก็
มีเรือใช่มอยู่ที่เรือเนี่ยแล้วก็ไปหาปลา
หมึก
เนี่ยปลาหมึกแล้วก็จับปลาหมึกขึ้นมาแล้ว
ก็กินเป็นซาชิมิอืซึ่งผู้หญิงเป็นคนกิน
ซาชิมินะแต่ผู้หญิงไม่เคยกินปลาหมึกที่
เป็นซาชิมิอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนแล้วก็เห็นแล้ว
ก็คิดไม่เอาไม่อยากกินเพราะว่าเราเคยกิน
หอยใช่มยหอยอืหอยเนี่ยเออหอยนางรมยเนี่ย
ก็เป็นซาชิมิเคยกินนะหดิบนะคะมันยังดิบ
ใช่มยยังไม่ได้เอาไปบาร์บีคิวเอาไปต้มนะ
คะแต่ปลาหมึกเนี่ยไม่เคยนะคะไม่เคยกินอื
แล้วครูฟ้าครูฟ้าคิดออกอีกมมว่าครูฟ้าไม่
เคยทำอะไรอีกอาจจะเป็นกินดูหรือว่าทำครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะเอาเรื่องอะไรก่อนดดีครูฟ้าไม่เคย
ไม่เคย
อะไรห้ะอะไรคะเนี่ยเครื่องบินคู่ฟ้าเคย
ขึ้นเครื่องบินไม่ใช่หรอ
กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็เชียงใหม่
ไงครูฟ้าไม่เคยไปต่างประเทศค่ะนักเรียน
อ๋อครูฟ้าจะไม่เคยขึ้นเครื่องบินใช่มย
อันเนี้ยในประเทศไทย coming  soon นะคะ
ครูฟ้าอ่าแล้วครูฟ้าก็ไม่เคยไปใช่มั้ย
ญี่ปุ่น
อื
เกาหลี
ยูโรปอ่าเนี่ยฟากไม่เคยไม่เคยออครูฟ้าไม่
เคยไปต่างประเทศอืมครูฟ้าไม่เคยไปต่าง
ประเทศเลยครูฟ้าอยู่แค่ประเทศไทยไทยไทย
ไทยไทไทยไทยนะคะะไทย 17 ปีแล้วใช่ค่ะูฟ้า
อยู่แต่ประเทศไทยเท่านั้นเออไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าก็จะได้ขึ้นเครื่องบินไปต่าง
ประเทศออืครูฟ้าก็เลยไม่เคยขึ้นเครื่อง
บินไปต่างประเทศไม่เคยไปอเมริกาไม่เคยไป
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์ไม่เคยไปไม่เคยไป
ออสเตรเลียอะไรอย่างเงี้ยอืเนาไม่เคยแล้ว
ฟูฟ้ามีอีกมยที่ฟูฟ้าไม่เคยทำที่ถ้าครู
ฟ้าคิดออกอีกมั้ยคะมีอะไรอืมที่ครูฟ้าไม่
เคยทำเหรอคะอือครูฟ้าไม่
เคยไม่เคย
อะไรอันนี้หน้าครูฟ้าใช่มยหน้าของครู
ฟ้าใช่
ค่ะผมผมม้าหูผมครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าไม่เคยทำจมูก
อืไม่เคยทำจมูกไม่เคยทำตาไม่เคยทำปากใช่ม
บางคนจะไปหาคุณหมอแล้วก็คุณหมอก็มีมีดค่ะ
อันนี้มีดเหรอคะอ๋อท้าค่ะจมูกเราเล็กๆใช่
ไหมมคุณหมอก็มีมีดแล้วก็ใส่ซิลิโคนก็อื
จมูกเราก็จะโด่งขึ้นอันนี้จมูกครูหญิงใช่
มั้ยคะ Before แล้วก็จมูกครูหญิงหลังจาก
ไปหาคุณหมอเสร็จแล้วอ๋อครูฟ้าไม่เคยทำเลย
หน้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตั้งแต่เกิด
มาจนถึง
202  3 เนี่ยหน้าก็เหมือนเดิมจมูกเหมือน
เดิมตาเหมือนเดิมปากเหมือนเดิมอืเหมือนเด
หน้าด้วยเนาะหน้าก็เหมือนเดิมออครูฟ้าไม่
เคยทำอะไรเลยอันนี้นักเรียนดูหน้าครูหญิง
ก็น่าจะเข้าใจนะคะว่าครูหญิงก็ไม่เคยทำ
อะไรที่หน้าเหมือนกันนะคะเหมือนครูฟ้า
เนาะหน้าเหมือนเดิมปากคอเอไม่ต้องก็ได้นะ
คะปากก็ไม่ได้ทำนะไม่ได้ฉีดอะไรด้วยนะคะ
นักเรียนนี่แหละค่ะก็คือสิ่งที่เรา 2 คน
คิดกันว่าเอ้อเนี่ยเราไม่เคยทำใช่มั้ยบาง
คนอาจจะเคยทำอเรา 2 คนเนี่ยไม่เคยทำเลย
แล้วนักเรียนมีอะไรที่ไม่เคยทำอืก็
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวดีโอนี้ครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเราเจอกัน
ใหม่วดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ